if you are watching this video right now
then I am sure that you are someone
interested in learning psychology
here are the list of books that will
help you understand human psychology
better
one
influence science and practice
by Robert Ciel deeney
for readers of any age this book is a
must read
it explains all the methods of
persuasion used by people on a daily
basis and how many are completely
unaware of them
reciprocation commitment consistency
social proof liking Authority and
scarcity are the six tools of persuasion
that are covered in this book
while reading the book one will be
easily able to relate it to their
everyday life and see how people use
these tools to manipulate us
if you want to understand how influence
works this book is for you
2.
Thinking Fast and Slow
by Daniel Kahneman
Thinking Fast and Slow is one of the
best psychology books ever published
the life work of Nobel prize winning
psychologist Daniel Kahneman it outlines
better than anything else the ways in
which humans fool themselves and how our
thoughts influence our Behavior
this book shows you how two systems in
our brain are constantly fighting over
control of our behavior and actions and
teaches you the many ways in which this
leads to errors in memory judgment and
decisions and what we can do about it
three
The Art of Seduction
by Robert Greene
written in Robert Greene's typical style
of demonstrating Universal principles
via historical examples this book is
both entertaining and informative
not only a book about sexual seduction
but rather a universal guide on
seduction in the most general terms
whether it be politically socially or
otherwise it's a book that should be
read by all
not only you will understand yourself
and your relationships but applying
these principles will help you across
your personal and professional lives
4.
flow the psychology of optimal
experience
by mihai six sent mahali
this book explores how we can experience
enjoyment in our lives by controlling
our attention and strengthening our
resolve
this is achieved by being immersed in an
activity or subject that makes us
neither anxious nor bored
in this Flow State we lose our
self-consciousness selfishness and sense
of time
using goal setting and immediate
feedback we can achieve a state of flow
that improves our relationship with work
increases our self-worth and gives our
lives meaning
five
rules for life an antidote to chaos
by Jordan Peterson
this book is everything you expect from
Peterson and more
crafted as a self-help style book it
beautifully interweaves history religion
science and philosophy into a highly
pragmatic book on how to be a fulfilled
successful better human being
it is entertaining self-help manual for
young people that lays out a set of
simple principles that can help us
become more disciplined behave better
act with integrity and balance Our Lives
while enjoying them as much as we can
thank you for watching